nous sommes à zapourritza devant un
centre pour les réfugiés ces personnes
viennent de la ville des Nero d'art où
se trouve la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'Europe ils ont fui
puisqu'elle est actuellement
occupée par les Russes ici ils viennent
chercher du réconfort de la nourriture
mais aussi une aide psychologique
à Liona et volontaire comme beaucoup
elle travaillait à la centrale
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'elle désire cette
tenter de rendre la vie un peu plus
facile à tous et déplacer mais certains
produits essentiellement
le centre a une pénurie de protection
hygiénique nous ne recevons pas assez de
nos donateurs c'est la même chose avec
les couvertures et les vêtements chauds
pour le moment nous en avons reçu 200 et
nous essayons de voir comment faire pour
les partager entre 5000 personnes
nous sommes vraiment reconnaissants
envers ce centre pour la bonne qualité
de la nourriture qui nous est fournie
les serviettes de toilette la nourriture
pour les enfants et les protections
hygiéniques vraiment merci
ici est stocké l'aide d'humanitaire
internationale vous pouvez trouver des
dons de la Croix-Rouge française mais
aussi de la Croix-Rouge danoise ou
encore des pâtes qui viennent du crâne
et puis il y a aussi découvertes des
boîtes de conserve tout est fait ici
pour pouvoir aider au maximum les
réfugiés
au Lexi est un conseiller municipal mais
aussi un ancienne employé de la centrale
nucléaire il a fui début juillet les
Russes le rechercher encore traumatisés
par ces mois passés auprès d'eux il a
perdu 15 kilos
les Russes mettent la pression
psychologiquement sur les employés de la
centrale pour qu'il signe des contrats
avec les autorités russes en charge du
nucléaire la plupart ne veulent pas
signer mais les Russes arrêtent des
employés au hasard certains
disparaissent pendant plusieurs semaines
d'autres sont toujours en prison
[Musique]
de la population a quitté la ville des
Neruda 15000 personnes se trouvent
toujours sur place dont des employés de
la centrale nucléaire leur expertise est
essentielle au bon fonctionnement de
cette centrale mais il travaille sous la
pression constante des Russes